nous sommes des êtres de désir et dire
que nous sommes des êtres de désir ce
n'est pas seulement dire à la manière de
Platon que nous sommes des êtres de
manque oui nous sommes des êtres de
manque nous sommes des êtres
d'insatisfaction car on sait que le
désir sitôt satisfait va sans
précédentes mais ce que veut dire
Spinoza va plus loin ce que veut dire
Spinoza c'est que le désir fait de nous
des êtres de puissance le désir est ce
qui en nous poussant à le satisfaire
nous pousse à agir pour le satisfaire la
fin nous pousse à travailler pour manger
le désir sexuel nous pousse à séduire
pour nous accoupler le désir de gloire
nous pousse à oeuvrer pour la postérité
et donc sans désir nous n'agirons plus
on accomplirions plus le désir est
puissant parce que le désir nous met en
mouvement